d'ailleurs je me demande en multi aux
petits aux deux pour pourquoi faire non
pas du tout alors moi certainement pas
donc moi je suis assez heureux comme ça
vraiment pas du tout pourquoi ce sera
ailleurs en europe que comme vous dites
d'ailleurs pourquoi le demain pour avoir
un mode plus que je pourrai pas me
prononcer d'ailleurs d'ailleurs écouté
je vous dis rentre pas thorez
entre-temps pèse entre nous qu'est ce
que c'est que le qu'est ce que c'est que
le bonheur voulez-vous me dire non mais
c'est vrai vous pensez peut-être que moi
c'est pas compliqué je me dirais c'était
une promesse que ce fait l'esprit d'un
mois que ce fait l'esprit moi il ne
tenait jamais jamais jamais une tonnerre
et je tentais dessus ah non pour faire
mon bonheur non non non non ça ça on est
heureux on est heureux toujours contre
quelqu'un c'est pas vrai ça on est très
content et on est heureux de ce qu'on
n'a pas on cherche toujours ce qu'on n'a
pas et d'ailleurs un manteau de fourrure
par exemple unsa chevaux la ronge en
mauricie chevaux un col de fourrure ou
manteau de fourrure à sa sage fait
remarquer et c'est à ce moment là que le
malheur commente madame quand vous
l'avez oui le malheur le malheur le
malheur le malheur arrive
le malheur commence pourquoi
commence-t-il
parce que le temps le temps arrive la
pendue à à à si on pouvait arrêter le
temps et justement on ne peut pas
d'accord c'est pas le temps qui passe
c'est nous non non le bonheur c'est trop
de souci ça cesser c'était on n'est
jamais tranquille mais c'est trop
fragile ténu cristal ce nouveau nom et
puis c'est pas ça seulement
mais le bonheur essayait de dire le
bonheur sans avoir peur ça ça explose
comme une explosion un tueur helmand et
ça se prolonge bonheur bonheur nokia me
fait peur
non non non moi moi moi n'ont jamais
jamais non alors ça si vous voulez
vraiment envie de vous dire la vérité je
vous le dirai il n'y a pas de bonheur
sans cerutti quai et c'est là ce sens et
qui tirait ses rues tous ses coups de
sang sans la certitude la permanence
voilà ce qui fait le bonheur c'est la
permanence
si vous voulez être heureux faites comme
moi voilà je suis pessimiste à sa
demande du boulot ça se passe comme ça
il faut il penser faut être inventif
faut être imaginatif ça
tous les joueurs moi j'avance du malheur
les plus neufs le plus invraisemblable
je me dis bon maintien par exemple
aujourd'hui je me disais c'est pas la
peine que j'y aille
il y aura pas de métro je pourrais pas
venir il y aura la grève c'est pas vrai
c'est demain aa je me disais mais il est
dommage demain il va pleuvoir et c'est
du tout je suis en garde sur le carreau
ce cd perle des perles et qui coûte tout
le monde évite et puis non je me dit une
femme
pourquoi faire pour être propre et n'ont
jamais trompée elle l'a toujours dit ah
ah non non non non et tous les jours
tous les jours croyez moi tous les jours
j'avais avant un truc nouveau un truc
sensationnel votre mortels demain je
serai en bouillie en bouillie par un
camion et ma femme aura des malheurs
plus de sa vie et à l'heure à 10
millions d'êtres nomura qu'à 110 ans la
vie ne peux plus me suivre c'est moi le
plus fort rien viennent peu plus de
surprendre
tenez plus vous serez pessimiste si vous
sujets mâles sont plus vous serez
heureux rêver le pire ce soir et je vous
promets demain des matins triomphant
émerveillé dans la joie et puis alors
personne ne pourra vous l'apprendre
celle là nick and in nyc khrouchtchev
eureka 2h15 eux
eureka le bonheur voilà le bonheur c'est
bien joué même si on n'a pas de jeu à
moi de donner c'est ça le bonheur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lui c'est lui c'est le cinéma
pourquoi pas je me rappelle moi même
justement un jour avoir participé à une
avoir participé à une superproduction
ray qui mène une production mais qui
réparait qui mène à usa et éducatives en
même temps mais sur les classiques
français justement
et là c'était une scène non on ne badine
pas avec malo celui d'alpha dessus ne
badine pas avec l'amour d'afro jazz in
pas avec la fossette hafside le staff de
l'ami de la récente
bref la scène 2 7 2 avec père dit que
verdict 1 et maquillés alors maquille et
evry - camille sée camille les brainois
vous l'auriez vu et moi même je la
voulais pour la première fois aussi
jolie dans sa petite robe avec son dock
taubaté kevin et son décolleté son
décolleté très bas derrière toute
fraîche tout c'est s'attirer tout ça
c'est dire sa sincérité
vraiment vraiment vraiment innocente
non vraiment le personnage et moi j'ai
un atout immédiatement je sentirai trac
fou hein je pouvais plus c'est à ce
moment là que j'entends un cri
moteur cris le moteur enseigne le
message le message le réalisateur et le
machiniste claque ça tapait tu tapes sa
plaquette face à pareil on ne badine pas
si 112e
bref un silence mais un silence
narrant tandis miauler une bouche on a
entendu voler une mouche violer une vie
tellement c'était de la magie pris par
l'émotion quand même je commence à dés
les premiers pots vous pouvez me croire
dès les premiers mots des machines war
sorti leur chimiste il s'appelait
machinistes sortez les mouchoirs
si rien payer même aux endroits où on ne
rit pas d'habitude avec sa galerie
s'était mise
franchement quand je vois ça obama qui
maquille camille qui me répond au boom
pas de faire vos meux vous ne faites
peur mais c'est à ce moment là qu est l
pas fouiller la malheureuse il ya des
vaches mais moi je ne perds pas mon
françois au contraire bon sang froid je
lui dis va te maquilles battant
d'ailleurs ce texte retourne trouvent
etc
vous savez vous connaissez tous les
hommes sont menteurs inconstante vos
faux bavard hippocrate il corpo creuse y
croit peu orgueilleux il lui ils sont
tous comme ça et toutes les femmes sont
son père fille artificieuse archi
vicieuse vaniteuse mais on aime et on
peut se dire c'est moi qui ai vécu et
non un être factrice créée par mon oeil
et mon oeil
et c'est à ce moment là par mois en
anglais par mont faron d'ailleurs à ce
moment là franchement la couper et il
faut vous dire elle devait me casser
pourquoi une fausse peau tête sur la
tige une potiche sur l'instruction sur
le crâne
elle se tombe enceinte d'un côté qui
était en marche vraiment je tombe en
syncope
au moins bien que le match nul là j'ai
une audition qui est arrivé et qui m'a
dit bravo
bon pour le son tout ce que j'entends et
puis fait le son c'était moi quand même
musset
alors edou edou célibataire bien non
vous marier we may use of nom et à
marcher
les noms visuel de votre femme non
visuelles dates et lieux de notre
mariage
je ne peux pas vous croyez voir si
justement c'était ce que je valais je
reviendrai monsieur ne copiez pas par
dessus le marché
non non non ça c'est s'il ya une cuisine
que je n'aime pas du tout c'est ma paye
d'infos laziale ma feuille d'impôts mais
jeu et même loin de 3000 est loin de
2000 et de moi l'idée de vous donner des
explications c'est évident mais c'est
exclu l'idée des éclaircissements à
revoir les nouvelles complications de la
notice simplificatrice mais je crois
pouvoir ici sans une tribu dans ce faire
profiter de mon expérience
ceux qui chaque année comme comme voix
devant leur feuille d'impôt la piste de
paix n'avance pas lisse un de peur car
si comme l'a dit gerville dans l'énéide
comme la vie dire gilles comme la vida
de l'adie bourvil l'a dit socrate ou
dases fort tu vas nous jatte aux
affaires ohada au gouda daouda d'autres
c'est du latin
enfin ça veut dire faut du culot pour
réussir et les autres ne doivent pas se
laisser dominer par ce complexe de
culpabilité
c'est par ce complexe de luke blake
dewitt de ligue b a culbuté de que vous
connaissez bien et qui les empêchera
toujours de bien à digérer la rédiger et
c'est pourquoi moi qui vous parle je
fuis trouvé mon certes espère c'est mon
père pasteur mon père mon père est mon
son remplaçant d'ailleurs je lui
demander de bien vouloir jeter un tout
petit look est un tout petit coup doute
que vous louez une oeillade sur ma
première déclaration
ma première avec ma première feuille
c'est à dire c'était pas ma première fut
la première à effet des fat et j'avais
fait des pâtes et il ya des personnes
qui ont la plume facile moi c'est la
langue aussi utile aujourd'hui on
n'écrit plus on parle enfin bref la
deuxième j'avais déclaré trop
la troisième je n'ai plus rien déclaré
du tout la quatrième déjà vu plus de
feuilles à fabrègues c'était la septième
et bien je suis contrôleur mettez vous
désirez après monsieur si vous êtes trop
longues heures si vous êtes trop content
trop si vous l'êtes
ça tombe bien parce que justement je
crains que vous ne vous soyez vous voyez
vous ne vous soyez foutu de leye fait
erreur dans leurs auteurs des poteaux
qui se demandent le report des poteaux à
la page 2 voyons d'abord la page 1 et il
faut pas y étaient bâties je ne vois
rien je dis justement feu moi non plus
et non bâti à sa non bâti gens manquent
pas hélas
et bien leur aaa
s'il faut payer il faut payer résidences
secondaires secondaires très secondaire
mais j'en ai qu elle en tout cas je
n'étais pas forcé de lui dire que
j'avais été à la santé pour ma mère me
que j'avais été à la mer pour ma santé
et personnes à votre service personne ne
vous piché fan moi il me dit vous ficher
padma vous fait tout tout seul une ombre
bien sûr j'ai ma femme et c'est tout
c'est pas le facteur l'éboueur dame au
ciel que nous sommes nul ne peut se
vanter de se passer des hommes que je
lui dis mais vous cacher des cachets
pardon je fous là des salaires qui sont
presque invisibles pouvait pas lui
avouer que c'était les cachets de la
radio d'arrêter les illusions de la
radio des révoltés de la snrt est que
j'avais frauduleusement doublé par souci
de la vraisemblance déjà votre compte et
vous souhaitez vous qui sont d'ailleurs
à nantes a du coup t'as pas tout papa
pas du tout non si c'est la somme en
somme comme son bras de payer plus 10%
après la date d avis mais après quelle
date
ça j'en sais rien ça dépend du rôle mais
10% c'est sûr
alors là j'ai compris et je n'ai rien
dit je ne me suis pas laissé faire
j'ai filé à la poste et j'ai tout payé
d'un seul coup 10% à hasnon en ajoutant
sur mon talent sur mon talon monsieur
c'est peut être un devoir pour tous
francs mais soyez un français moyen de
payer ses pinceaux de ppc ayew 2 2
gasquet mais c'est un devoir envers ses
enfants de ne pas verser un centime de
plus et en cross country home en
proscrit en 30 ans proche or en bas et
vous devez le savoir vous que vous êtes
père de ma fille
vous êtes père de famille lieu comme moi
ah non il faut être bon mais complété
jamais
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai jacqueline
joubert mais je ne sais pas mais c'est
pas parce que j'ai des facilités
d'équitation que j'ai des facilités des
kilos sion des colis d'élocution que je
suis non membres lions d'ingres mon
violon grains ce moment mon dada c'est
la cuisine la cuisine sader ce n'est pas
ce que l'on mange qui nourrit mais ce
que l'on digère tout le monde le sait et
c'est justement parce que pernod
n'ignore pas ce que personne ni rogne
mieux parce que tout le monde n'oublie
que j'ai voulu vous dédié cette vérité
des diététique des vite et éthiques
d'une certaine vérité quotidienne et
éternelle éternel ya qu en l'illustrant
d'un exemple pour vous éclairer ya qu
une bonne façon au fond de faire le
boeuf mais au fond le boeuf me torrent
le mof ni aux murs entend le must le
d'ailleurs il ya certainement une erreur
dans le mou français riez vous que les
italiens des myron donne en couronne il
on raisonne ils ont raison puisqu'on
dispose la bonne on dispose la bonne la
bonne viande en en couronne enfin bref
cette recette à l'essence à s'essayer à
celle ci tout s'arrange alors vous
commencez par consommer tenant vous
consommez je veux dire vous commencez
par émincés la viande savez au couteau
pas à la râpe 6 à 700 grappe à 700
grammes de bon boeuf bouilli de
préférence un morceau que vous avez
choisi vous même chez votre boucher dans
sa partie grassouillette pas du boucher
alors vous débouchez aussi vous émincés
aussi j'aime assez et émincer 3 ou canio
tron cm3 ou crac oignons 3 ou 3 ou 4 3
où cette petite savez cette que vous
mettez dans une sauteuse pour les faire
bondir blanc dire pardon part d'un blanc
dire en compagnie d'un petit morceau de
beurre et si cet oignon de fond tu de
fous du dessus et c'est toute cette
fondue d'oignons que vous épie cc2s
épices et cpe liés nous et voilà de
farine de farine comme quantité bas il
faut une bonne cuillère y ait une bonne
cure vieillit 2
une culture à faye de passer à trois
doigts ou trois passes et al nature
n'ait pas de cou hier sous la main un de
cas n'oubliez pas de la remuée souvent
si vous voulez la faire sourire roussir
pardon puis vous là des glaces et d'un
demi des six litres de vinaigre fort et
vous la paire et mon dieu après arnould
blier pas surtout à j'allais l'oublier
moi même d'ajouter une pure et une
plutôt exactement une cuillérée de
tomates en purée de tomate enrhumé au en
purée et une pincée une seule pensée de
hachis percée vous voyez que c'est pas
qu'on coûte de persil haché le lien
alors une fois cuit votre oignons par
votre oignons votre oignons à dijon vos
oignons elle s'est prêtée par vos
oignons bien sûr à ses moignons d'une
même ballard autant vous gardez votre
union alors votre oignons puis vous
quittez le boeuf
je veux dire le veuf vous suivez loi
fait et pendant un quart d'heure vous
n'avez plus qu'à le regarder cuir alors
je vous cache pas nous serons obligés de
rectifier la fadeur inévitable du boeuf
bougies du boeuf bouilli poivre ou brun
pain brun brin de branches de thym quoi
ou vin blanc vin blanc vin blanc ou une
miette tout petit verre de coni devant
nous ne cherchons pas de complication
car n'oublions jamais que ce sont les
savons les saveurs dans la déglutition
les saveurs premièrement qui datent de
fou qui flatte le goût et deuxièmement
qu'ils suscitent les organes digestifs
savait pas si cette double vertus
digestives qui fait que nous dire autant
nous mire autant je veux dire miro ton
de le mot que je cherchais qui fonde se
mirent au temps où mironton la preuve
que c'est à la cuisine et du soir au
matin que mijote notre destin cqfd servi
cqfd c'est une abréviation que je viens
d'imaginer à l'instant même pour vous
permettre de tout résumé de tout retenir
cqfd condiments et qualité facilité pour
digérer c'est toute la vie
[Musique]
je m'étais je m'étais promis de vous
dire pour commencer une très courte
fable une petite fable de la fontaine
c'est tout le monde connaît stéphane en
laine de fallout 9 mon auteur favori le
corps barré de renou le robot le barbeau
le cornard nuque le corner on se regarde
je ne mangeais pas voulu le jeu vous en
dire une autre toujours de ta font
toujours de facto devenue du même auteur
le coche et malouche et ma douche le
moche et s'accrochant avec le junior
maintenant oui je me rends bien compte
que je baille ouf c'est que la bouffe ja
la fouille de la bafouille latéralement
bafoue unités marland militairement
je me rends j'aimerais vous dire
franchement je m'attendais pas à vanter
en arrivant à voir tant de monde de man
voient leur temps demandant tout autour
de toi que tu autour me dois au tourne
mais même dernier roi humaine dernière
merde tu m aimes mes passagers la funky
gorge j'ai la langue elfique lourches la
langue si je peux plus utiliser des mots
peu plus articulé menés depuis un
stimulant à limoux
je vais vous le dire en anglais aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
catherine ailleurs le string et aux
goûts des fonctions ariane full of
eichmann a fait mouche en dessous si
ceux ci sont bénévoles tous 6 puis
napoles sommet n'était pas le film orbi
du mof difformes
j'aurais dû le dire en japonais je
savais c'est pour ça je ne voulais pas
venir l'avais dit je l'avais d'immigrés
du chef michel ducret avec sim elle a su
mer hachée ou pas trop je viens unis non
ne me forcez pas il m'a dit mais si
allons mener vers 8h30 ou prendrait la
pire on veut vous prendrai la parole je
le lui ai dit moi les deux formats
vous le connaissez fister insisté
tellement insisté alors moi je voulais
montrer qu'à l'occasion je trouvais à
différents médias le djia rue et gaga
est gâteux galets savez c'est terrible a
fait tous pareils un flot d'appels 1 0
ap un défaut comme ça vous ne vous ne
croyez pas que c'est ça qui m'a fait
rater mon deuxième mariage mon deuxième
run ullmann avant le troisième bailleur
et pourtant je vous donne ma parole
d'honneur ma fille sunny était mal de
fois et cette méfiance était vraiment
mort folle de moi
moi j'en étais mouffard où je n'avais
pas fou mais room amoureux vous fout oui
mais en n'ayant rien à faire et c'est
comme ça depuis ce matin comme le matin
du jour de mes fils ryan sa démission en
fin de mon mariage mariage raté
d'ailleurs dès le matin j'avais eu un
mauvais c'est pour mi temps ça sert à
rien mauvais points de vente y sent
vraiment c'est justement douter quand je
me suis levé j'ai vu une araignée
je m'étais dit au site règne du gratin
machin a régné du canal vers 10 heures
c'est pas la peine j'ai appris dans les
rangs j'avais prévenu qui après ont
arriverait jamais exclu mézois esprit
mezouar
[Applaudissements]
oui
oui je vous dois une confidence cas sur
elle et j'ai eu l'occasion de montrer
qu'il avait des facilités d'équitation
kit des facilités d'équitation
dépollution des lots q sion mais jamais
nous volions dingue j'ai un violon grade
un dada et mon dada c'est la cuisine
surtout l'attaqué privé surtout la
patiente rizla pas les gâteaux ou ça
c'est pas pour moi que j'en mange pas
faim je mange plus ça me faisait grossir
j'ai arrêté à temps non c'est pour le
plaisir d'en faire ou dans le free
rejeter des crêpes par exemple pas
n'importe quel crêpes whaou
si vous voulez de l'inédit une
découverte puis j'ai fait l acteur du
faune à la foire du frotte plaph fait
une jolie comédienne qui rit maintenant
dans le bois des pistes dans le pain dit
dans le bas des pistes du bois de
vincennes
fabien est peut-être marcher sur la
marchande aurait coûté je passe les
détails
j'arrive aux proportions alors là c'est
très simple
retenez 3,3 points comme les trois de
gibraltar
ça veut dire 300 tonnes 300 g de farine
point quart de litre d'eau 3e et 3
cuillères à beurre doux je produis
nettoie
3 de glee rabeuf toi ou de l'huile comme
je n'ai même pas faire fausse de séjours
à gagner alors je défais marc alyn jeu
délais mara fit ma farine pour à pau
dans l'eau peu à peu dans le dos peu à
peu dans dans du lait ses meilleurs dans
du lait je les mange tient déjà je
mélange mélange jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'épaisseur de patras riou g de pâte
assez liquide
naturellement je me bats poêle à
chauffer sur le poil sur le gaz
si vous avez d'électricité et quand la
poêle et shun une goutte d'huile
naturellement et une mais une seule et
cuillères à carreaux de patrick erard
agathe de haramous une petite louche pas
ordinaire pas plus c'est une manie en
france de vouloir faire les crêpes trois
fois tombé tech pour un poids trop
faible selon les très petits une
dentelle toit du bruges
ah j'oubliais c'est à ce moment là que
vous laissez tomber en pluie quelques
grains de riz khan rosette
on a toujours des résonne rockhal le
même défi ou des fruits confits si vous
n'arrivez pas à retrouver les raisins
mais alors h et fréthun achèterait le
moment venu vous prenez alors comme ceux
ci la queue de la poêle à bois et voilà
le manche est sorti vous regardiez semer
revenu tout de suite et hop
alors ça c'est rien du tout à faire il
faut pas se laisser distraire d'un coup
sec du poignet vous lancez les 2 vaches
et la poêle est vrai massacre
vous lancez boulin vous pouvez aussi
lune vous gâcher l'autre et podor et oui
c'est vrai avez vous un grand place et
la pâte vous massacrer la photo ap la sq
d'ailleurs maintenant quand je fais des
crêpes
ma femme me laisse toute la cuisine
money 10 comprend avec toi on ne connaît
pas les points de chute
elle est gentille non parce que une fois
je l'avais laissé tomber ma crêpe par ma
femme je les ramasse et était pas cassé
je leur mise bien à poil ma femme ma foi
non alors comme je l'avais une bonne
cinquantaine les mettre à refroidir dans
un moule rond comme les traîtres elles
sont réussies les recouvrir de mort vers
l'inde démarre mal de purée de fruits
puisque c'est le but de la tête voyez
c'est à la portée d'un enfant et vous
mettez l'enfant au four que lentement au
four au moment de servir ajoutez un peu
de choses sucrées et c'est tout mais
retenez le nom céder ni la caisse ni des
câlinesse ni deux ni l'année ce qui les
fuit sa laine c'est un mot polonais
enfin c'est les crêpes mais des crêpes à
la confiture c'est ça l'originalité des
grès pas la fronti qu à la fonte aides à
des clubs
moi je mets les chocolats et c'est aussi
beau bref vous si vous n'avez pas sur le
gaz mettez de la confiture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]